blue States in particular  the kids were locked down and out of  school for the some of the longest  periods of time now we're seeing the  learning delays a lot of the social  delays and this affects people I would  say the lower class is more affected by  this as well a lot of the people that we  claim you know the the liberal claim to  care about they suffered the greatest  people are poor people are not as hell  they're sicker and  so I don't think it's  um I don't think it's weird that people  are looking around and saying I I don't  know what to do but I know whatever I've  been doing is not working so just voting  for the opposite party seems like the  the move